boa tarde a todos meu nome é ricardo
michel é um grande prazer estar aqui
falando pra essa platéia
a ufrj é referência nacional nas mais
diversas áreas e poder estar aqui
participando de reflexões sobre os
caminhos da universidade na educação é
realmente muito grande honra
é também muito difícil especialmente
quando a gente está na sombra dessas
imensas realizações que esse modelo de
universidade tem conquistado por essa
razão é preciso distinguir a realizações
das mais diversas áreas do conhecimento
da forma de conduzir o processo de
ensino aprendizado sobre essa forma é
que o planejado traçar algumas idéias
aqui na nossa graduação universitária
o estudante e assistir nossas palestras
ele resolve exercícios ele tenta
responder da melhor forma possível as
questões que a gente coloca pra ele
na universidade o estudante faz com a
cabeça
se fossemos representar o estudante do
ponto de vista do que ele faz na
universidade
nós teremos algo mais ou menos assim
isso porém não é uma pessoa de verdade
certamente não é aquele estudante que
entrou na universidade
querendo ser um professor uma engenheira
médico o cineasta
isso é o que nós fizemos dele uma pessoa
real e nas mais diversas cores tamanhos
gêneros necessidades e formas nossa
maneira de ensinar vem numa forma só pra
cabeça
a consequência disso é que para muitos
estudantes
existe uma diferença entre o mundo real
onde eles atuam com o corpo inteiro e o
mundo da sala de aula onde eles atuam é
somente com a cabeça
existe um distanciamento entre os
problemas que estudantes vivem no mundo
real isso e os problemas que nós
queremos que eles resolvam
outra característica do nosso processo
de ensino aprendizagem é que nós focamos
muito mais nas ferramentas do que nós do
que nas coisas que nós podemos fazer com
elas e por fim um terceiro aspecto é que
nós exigimos dos nossos alunos uma
confiança
que só é confirmada muitos anos depois
quando então e zagallo no já tem uma
razoável experiência profissional é a
confiança de que o conteúdo de qualquer
disciplina tem de fato alguma finalidade
a as construções mentais e as
habilidades que nós professores queremos
veicular uma certa disciplina nem sempre
são muito óbvias
na verdade o curso como um todo pode
parecer ter objetivos difusos
são objetivos bastante concretos mas é
difícil apresentar a importância deles
no contexto do ensino aprendizagem
durante o processo de ensino
aprendizagem
a consequência é que nós optamos por não
apresentar essa importância a gente
simplesmente disso estuda isso é
importante acredita em mim
a que acontece é que para muitos
estudantes essa questão do
distanciamento entre o mundo real e
aparente distanciamento entre o mundo
real eo mundo da universidade e se a
fixação nas ferramentas e tal acabam
criando uma sensação de não
pertencimento ou até de inadequação que
eu estou fazendo aqui e isso não é pra
mim
são frases demasiadamente ouvidos nos
corredores
o coordenador de curso há muito pouco
tempo e já escutei isso demais
eu admito que às vezes essa frase pode
ter outras origens como por exemplo uma
escolha adequada do curso por parte do
aluno ou até uma má avaliação das suas
prioridades pessoais mas muitas vezes é
isso vem da nossa falta de propaganda da
nossa simples falta de exploração de
contexto bom onde que nós encontramos
tá mais do que isso um aspecto
tremendamente importante essa sensação
de inadequação onde não pertencimento
se ela é freqüentemente presente nós
podemos ter um aluno a sensação de
frustração exaustão etc
se a gente olha isso a incerteza de que
todo o esforço despendido na
universidade vai ser recompensado por
uma carreira por um emprego na área
nós temos um contingente de pessoas em
situação de precisava então aonde nós
encontramos pessoas que estão animadas
em aprender ou pelo menos mesmo
aprendendo a duras penas estão animadas
com o processo
eu encontrei pessoas assim no movimento
maker a tendo identificado esse
movimento e tendo 16 identificado com
ele procure encontrar essas pessoas
procuram nos eventos e feiras onde elas
apareciam
conversei com o pessoal do onze do
carioca hackerspaces participei do hip
hop br participei do lado e mail space e
aprendi muito com essas pessoas num
movimento maker mas que é movimento make
bom
há um movimento meio que é caracterizado
por fazer coisas
simbolicamente por fazer coisas com as
mãos a gente sempre teve fazedores então
o que tem de novo aí que tem de novo
segundo chris anderson que é um é foi o
editor chefe da revista wired o que
caracteriza o distingue o maker de hoje
do inventor que a gente tinha antes
é um conjunto pequeno de aspectos um
deles é a dependência ou a vinculação
intensa com ferramentas digitais
o segundo é uma cultura onde a norma é o
compartilhamento de idéias ferramentas e
técnicas e finalmente uma padronização
de design que permite todo esse tipo de
interação fazer no contexto do movimento
maker não é o mesmo que construir alguma
coisa em casa ou ter um material
inovador é fazer parte de um coletivo de
fabricação que é meio fluido meio de
deslocalizado em função de existir
também no espaço digital
o fazer nessa era de acesso total à
informação implica em saber encontrar
informação implica em saber conectá lo a
um conjunto de saberes am
como vou dizer é que tem partes humanas
e partes digitais certo esse conjunto de
saberes formam uma rede onde o maker é
parte dessa rede ele não só a tua
localmente como ele também gera
informação
no caso da educação fundamental o
movimento maker deu origem às
estratégias do sistema e sting
essas estratégias a hoje que meu nome
mais genérico mais amplo significa
combinação de ciência tecnologia
engenharia arte e matemática
o esquema tenha sido aplicado em
diversos países do ensino fundamental
com excelentes resultados
aqui no brasil a já tem sido bastante
discutido para ensino fundamental mas
pouco se faz dele na área das
universidades têm experimentado alguma
coisa nessa área em duas disciplinas que
eu apresentei aqui na ufrj no curso de
licenciatura em química do instituto de
química
a primeira dessas disciplinas foi
química do cotidiano a onde os alunos
desenvolveram projetos utilizando
materiais que ele se encontrava em casa
na cozinha na farmácia na ferragem a
segunda dessas disciplinas foi criação
minha eu apresento ela ainda hoje é
laboratório de desenvolvimento e
avaliação de material didático onde os
alunos desenvolvem projetos para ensino
de química ensino através da química
a gente tem ficado cada vez mais no uso
de ferramentas digitais e quando têm
alunos suficientes na noção de
desenvolvimento coletivo a essa duas
disciplinas têm sido é bastante
importante bastante relevante tem me
ensinado também bastante como operar uma
disciplina utilizando esses conceitos
mas tem as perguntas que são que vem daí
como por exemplo como extensivamente eu
posso utilizar os conceitos em uma
disciplina na universidade ou ainda
seria possível mesmo criar um curso
baseado nesses conceitos um curso
inteiro baseado neles seria um razoável
desafio e mas aqui na universidade nós
ensinamos a gerir desafio
gerir riscos um dos desafios
naturalmente é controlar o tempo numa
disciplina baseada em projetos
outro dos desafios é ter a garantia de
que um dado assunto vai ser tratado em
profundidade
nós podemos ter assuntos que sequer vão
ser tratados na sua totalidade é um
risco possível podia tentar contrapor a
isso os argumentos de uma maior
valorização dos saberes
quando se trabalha com disciplinas
baseadas em projetos uma vez que o aluno
está no projeto do seu interesse ele
precisa de uma informação momento que
ele adquire essa informação ela passa a
ter relevância foi ela aparece ela se
fixa num determinado contexto que é
relevante para o aluno
portanto a gente espera que tenha maior
fixação é importante lembrar que dentro
do sistema atual de disciplinas e cursos
nós não temos a menor garantia de que
uma dada à disciplina ou de uma menor
garantia de que nós teremos alguma
conquista de profundidade ou de retenção
do assunto discutido
essa noção de maior fã de vínculo do
aluno com o projecto implica um aluno
gostar do projecto implica na
possibilidade mesmo de ele poder
escolher o projeto a fazer ou até mesmo
de participar na seleção no
desenvolvimento desse projeto aqui na
ufrj temos vários projetos que são
baseados sobre esses pilares alguns
deles com diversos deles tem apoio de
diversos professores
vou falar de dois deles o pessoal do
minerva rockets e minerva rádios que com
os quais eu tenho colaborado a eles
criam e produzem coisas com as mãos e
tem sido uma honra trabalhar com eles eu
tenho aprendido muito com o ganho
individual e coletivo das pessoas nesses
dois projetos além das propostas de
disciplinas baseadas em projetos é o a
partir delas a gente vê a necessidade de
termos espaços de fabricação e esse
arranjo sugere a necessidade de
laboratórios abertos e espaços de
experimentação tenta falar o que são
eles
um espaço de fabricação é um espaço
maker dentro da universidade espaço de
fabricação é onde o aluno encontra as
ferramentas e conhecimento para produzir
coisas eu não tenho ideia como seria
espaço de fabricação para todas as áreas
e fazeres da universidade um espaço de
fabricação para engenharia poderia
conter uma impressora 3d uma máquina de
corte laser por exemplo talvez um espaço
para a nutrição pudesse ter uma cozinha
acessível de uso livre ou uma tem um
espaço onde o estudante pudesse produzir
a sua própria variedade de queijos 11
laboratório aberto não é nada mais do
que um laboratório como esses que nós já
temos por aí
é um laboratório onde o aluno poderia
utilizar o espaço e os materiais para
desenvolver pesquisas do seu interesse
mas que são também da vocação do
laboratório seria a iniciativa mais
fácil de ser implementada porque nós já
temos os laboratórios instalados e um
espaço de experimentação operariano uma
região cinzenta entre um espaço de
fabricação e um laboratório aberto é
onde o aluno poderia ir pra testar uma
idéia é fazer um pequeno experimento
obter algum material simples que ele
precisa para alguma outra coisa aqui na
ufrj nós podemos falar da brilhante
iniciativa do rambo que poderia ser
descrita a partir desses princípios que
eu apresentei aqui agora sobre
laboratórios abertos eu em 2008 e 2014 e
2015 abrir um laboratório que coordenava
uma unidade do ct
a idéia é que qualquer aluno que
quisesse produzir qualquer coisa
impressão 3d ou produzir qualquer
equipamento eletrônico e eletrônica
digital baseado em heroína etc
poderia usar nossos materiais
ferramentas ea nossa expertise liberei
um macaco razoável quantidade de tempo
para colaborar com esse projeto para
tocar esse projeto
tivemos poucos alunos mas o resultado
foi excelente
de fato muitos deles queriam produzir
bonequinhos o pokémon
não tudo bem faz parte era um dos riscos
em princípio eu ensinei eles a escolha
material a operar a impressora a
discutimos um bocado sobre direitos
autorais
ele saiu de lá com que eles queriam um
bocado mais mas o interessante é que em
algumas semanas alguns desses alunos
estavam de volta às demandas eram outras
eles queriam agora engrenagem suportes
pequenas peças para os laboratórios
eles tinham se apropriado do
conhecimento
tentando resolver projetos do interesse
deles e agora eles estavam sendo capazes
de reconhecer problemas e sabendo como
resolvê los no mundo real
então eu acredito fosse um extremo
sucesso o nosso nosso experimento essa
ideia de disciplinas baseadas em
projetos e espaços de fabricação de
experimentação e laboratórios abertos
sugere a necessidade de disciplinas e
cursos sob demanda
isso é que atenda à necessidade dos
alunos nessas situações nesses projetos
a pensão um pouco mais além a gente
poderia até mesmo imaginar uma proposta
de cocriação de currículos
combinando esse esforço de fabricação de
produzir coisas dos alunos com saberes
já disponíveis na universidade tanto no
seu corpo docente quanto no seu corpo
técnico administrativo
nós poderemos produzir uma nova rede de
saberes e de pessoas
bom a habilidade de fazer perguntas de
localizar o seu lugar num grupo de
ocupar esse lugar é uma habilidade que
muitas pessoas têm desde antes de entrar
no sistema educativo lá atrás no ensino
fundamental mas não são habilidades
cultivadas são às vezes ativamente
suprimidos no nosso processo de ensino
aprendizagem e que nós professores
precisamos aprender a cultivá las aqui
dentro são habilidades essenciais se nós
quisermos qualquer tipo de transformação
é verdadeira
nós também precisamos modificar um
bocado a nossa forma de trabalho é bem
difícil é conduzir os alunos
especialmente nas etapas iniciais de
trabalhos com projetos onde eles têm
imensa as liberdades e responsabilidades
certamente temos que aperfeiçoar o nosso
processo didático e teremos que ter
algum treinamento em gestão de pessoas
certamente também seria necessária novas
formas de avaliação provas não são
adequadas mesmo agora e muito menos
nesse tipo de situação eu não tenho
propostas para isso é pôr em bom
por fim mas numa posição de honra
nós temos uma situação bastante
interessante que talvez devido à
natureza digital do movimento maker
talvez devido à época em que ele foi
criado essas ações são um movimento bem
que é profundamente inclusivo e gerador
de ações de inclusão
mesmo que nada mais do que eu disse aqui
possa um dia ser incorporado este
aspecto do movimento meio que deveria
poder ser incorporado já então tentando
responder à pergunta do evento como
reconstruir a universidade
qual o caminho a gente poderia seguir se
fosse assim tão fácil estava feliz
na verdade a nossa situação é mais
parecida com essa
como reconstruir a universidade
certamente revendo o nosso ponto de
vista
conectando as pessoas e seus interesses
a base sólida disponível na universidade
através de oportunidades de ação
ganharíamos muito em efetividade em
dimensão humana
ganharemos muito em conhecimento
conhecimento não há informação
conhecimento talvez não seja nenhum
direito
conhecimento é um poder e poder se
conquista
muito obrigado